as the lhc has been
working and running people are beginning
to ask the question what comes next in
the world of high energy physics
should there be another collider and
it's kind of become
an issue for some people because the
large hadron collider although it's
doing fantastic science it's measuring
quantities to amazingly high precision
if you think of it in terms of the
discovery of new particles
it's discovered one
which was the higgs back in 2012
which was what it was built for
exactly really an incredible thing that
has happened in my lifetime but it's not
found anything else it's not found any
evidence of dark matter which through
the world of supersymmetry it's not
found any evidence of more exotic things
perhaps like
extra dimensions or other new particles
it has demonstrated that we have a
effectively a
an interaction between the higgs and the
fermions a force acting there that we
need to understand better because we can
now probe that regime which we couldn't
before but the question is do we build
an even bigger collider and it was
brought to a forefront by the uh a
recent publication suggesting that there
might be uh what they call a future
circular collider based at cern that's
where the current large hadron collider
is the large hadron collider is
underground in a ring that's about 25
kilometers long
the future circular collider would be a
ring that's a hundred kilometers long
four times the length it would cost a
voter 10 to 20 billion pounds naturally
a question that you we need to ask
ourselves both as physicists but also
your society you know where do you want
to invest these large amounts of money
there was a particular article that that
at least within the particle physics
community was read a lot by sabine
hossenfelder in which she
said although
she accepted that probing fundamental
physics
through a particle accelerator is like
the best microscope there is to do that
the fact that we've only made this one
discovery and we don't have any great
ideas as to what is coming next in terms
of theory
perhaps we should be deferring building
maybe not even building a future
collider until we have our theories
firmly better established and then we
can perhaps go ahead once we've said
well this is almost certainly to be be
the way forward and
and therefore that will dictate
the form of any large collider rather
than kind of fumbling in the dark i
think that's a probably she would agree
with that that the way that we if we
go ahead right now we are we'll be
basing it on physics that we already
know but more speculative physics about
what's coming next and it's a really
important question to address for me
personally i think it's a it's a
it's there's not a clear-cut answer i i
remember back in the 1980s when the
large hadron collider was being put
forward and maybe even slightly earlier
people did think they knew what the
solution was they did think
that uh dark matter would be found in
what are known as wimps weakly
interacting massive particles there was
we talked about a wimp miracle
and there were natural candidates for
this wimps which were coming from
supersymmetry
the higgs mechanism had been suggested
back in the 60s and so there was a there
was in some sense a well-defined path to
go along and if i were in it the very
first conference i ever went to in 1983
was at the royal society and stephen
hawking gave a talk there in which he
said we will know everything by the end
of the century and it's all n equals
eight super gravity he called it it was
called and turned out not to be the case
there was an example where we did think
we knew where we were going and we the
decision on the lhc was made and you do
need to make these many years in advance
you know the lhc came into operation
2008 right 20 odd years nearly 30 years
after the initial proposal the proposal
for the future circular collider would
have it starting in 2050
because
you've got to build these things you've
got to develop the technology and are
you saying that the large hadron
collider
didn't end up
discovering the thing it was built to
discover it no it did the higgs you
you're quite right you said at the very
beginning its primary goal was to
discover the hicks but it had secondary
goals and there was a real feeling that
it would probably be able to if it found
the higgs it would probably find the
these wimp particles because there was
supersymmetric models which suggested
that wimp particles would be in the same
sort of mass range as the higgs that
wasn't the case and that wasn't the case
they have just not they've just not
shown up in fact no new particles have
shown up so the
argument for building the big circular
collider isn't there as strongly as it
was for the lhc in the sense of having a
whole series of particles that you think
you're going to find yeah as far as i
can tell there's not and in fact it
would be a case that we'd be building it
partly in order to
actually
use the la the upgraded lhc and of
course the lhc itself still has many
years left of its lifetime to go
um
be using it
not only as a discovery machine but to
to actually find new things that might
might be there but also to has a high
precision machine to help us understand
the standard model and in particular the
higgs and the interaction the higgs has
with fermions with the the things that
you and i are made of the quarks and the
leptons to help us understand those
interactions much much better because
another way of finding new physics
is to say here's my standard model
prediction for some very exotic process
then i go and measure that exotic
process and i find a difference
and it's
and the difference may only be in like
the tenth decimal place but if you're
sure about the calculations that have
gone into it and sure about the
measurements then there's you're probing
you're finding evidence of new physics
wow
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is it it's the detector and that's
one reason why you would go for a you
know a much
more powerful machine that can probe
into these new areas smaller length
scales higher energy where things might
pop up we just don't know it's one of
the frustrating things about this
there's two things that can go on here
you can build a new collider to find
a new particle and have some paradigm
change yeah or you can build one to just
like fine tune and get higher resolution
and better pictures
and they're two different arguments it
feels like yeah but in fine tuning
you're looking for differences right
it's not a case of i mean you it's
that's what you're always probing for
the way physics works right is we
basically we don't try to confirm models
we try to rule them out that's kind of
in our heads we try to find deviations
and that's what would this fine-tuning
it would be rather than having
you know
something smash you in the face and say
here i am this brand new particle look
at me i've revolutionized things
straight away it's a much more subtle
way of doing it you're finding
deviations from what standard model
would say
and and
nature is can be like this it can it can
hide
these new ingredients that make it very
difficult to find and if we don't build
something
we're not going to find them this way ed
i know it takes a long time to build
these things but still wouldn't it make
more sense to wait for the next
really
paradigm break yeah applausable theory
and the next peter higgs and then start
building something i think sabine's got
a very valid point here that you know
but but the question also is at what
stage
in that process do you say aha now it's
time to build my new
you know
future circular collider
because there are kind of two two
aspects to it one is
the technology involved in it i'm a
theorist but hey what do i know but i
believe the technology involved in this
is really complicated okay
you you they're always at the cutting
edge developing things so what the lhc
can do right today the back in the 1980s
people had no idea they'd be able to do
it at the level that they can do it
because technology has developed one of
the reasons they've been able to do it
is that there was always a funding
stream to help support the
superconducting magnets to help support
the development of the accelerator
technology the detector technology if
you put that on hold right and say okay
let's just let the theorists have a go
now for a while until we come up with
something what are these people going to
do they're not going to hang around
they're not going to play say yeah this
is okay let's just theories take about
five years let's go and do something
else they're going to leave
and the subject and the it runs the real
risk it is an expensive subject
it's like apollo they will leave and
that's it it'll be the end of it and
okay if you if you prepared to accept
that so be it that that's the nature of
it there is one possible route through
i've i and i think cern are playing this
um
they're playing for two possible
scenarios here there's another one which
is that
although they've come out with this
future collider circular collided paper
and i personally think it's really
exciting they've also sort of at the
same time come up with a with another
set of papers where they're looking at
actually what can we make use of what's
around cern at the moment
to actually probe different types of
physics which would still be looking at
the underlying fundamental physics of of
our universe but not
requiring you know really high energy
particle collisions and this is
motivated partly by the fact that we've
not seen any evidence of dark matter
we've not seen these massive dark matter
particles
and maybe
what what is actually going on in the
universe the
these equivalent dark matter particles
aren't very massive they may be really
light
and they don't interact very much with
us in which case it having a big
heavy large
hadron-like collider won't be the way to
see them we need more sophisticated
um
ready-made
precisely made detectors to pick up some
of these light particles like axions
specific axion detectors and so one
possibility is to actually look at um
for a set of
experiments
that that could be based around cern
using
the the the accelerators they've already
got and using some of the facilities
they've already got so just bolt better
experiments onto the existing ring the
user yeah so they use a
bolt is it like i was thinking about um
gently place
existing experience you know use use
what you've got and then and then
develop there are lots of else yeah i've
been there that was so exciting and and
of course you're building new things as
well but that's that's that's another
possible and
so why have i said that i could imagine
the community saying
okay
let's have this period where we we go
that route for a little while
let's keep the r d going for the for the
big accelerators
but during that period we can be probing
testing these these models of weak
coupling regimes like dark matter
particles
screening mechanisms which could account
for you know the the fifth force that
that that is could be driving the
acceleration of the universe but
meanwhile carry on with its r d invest
in the r d for the future accelerators
and then hopefully either some results
will come out of these new set of
proposals or some theoretical
developments will emerge which say yeah
this is the way we should be going
and then you can sort of decide okay now
we'll start the process on but there is
always this risk back in the 80s
people were absolutely certain i think
pretty certain apart that not absolutely
but fairly certain that wimps were the
way forward and that supersymmetry was
the way forward there was no question to
build the large hadron collider after
the
large electron positron collider it was
it was just the thing to do and it
turned out not to be
right it's uh
who knows that's the excitement of many
ways of working in these kind of fields
what would you do here because like
obviously you're biased and you're a
part of your physicist yeah but you do
live in a world where you also like
hospitals and yeah holes to be healed
and you have you have children growing
up in the world who need infrastructure
sure yeah yeah how do you think the
money should be spent it's so much money
this is a lot of money
um
i would spend it
and i because for a number of reasons
one is
you know it's not just the uk
contributing to cern cern has got 22
members it's got i don't know eight
affiliated members you know there's 30
countries here
we'll all contribute
they'll contribute over many many years
okay it's not as if this is
an immediate outlay so there's a
dispersion of the actual finance
of course hospitals need all the
facilities they can but
you know particle physics live in
hospitals right my you know my dear
father who passed away when i went to
the city hospital for him to have
radiology treatment
on the wall
is this amazing plaque i've tried to
find an image of it
that talks about the cyclotron
accelerator that they were using and
that's that was the particle physics of
the 40s 30s 40s 50s that is now in
medicine the mri scanner that was
invented
here at um
here at nottingham uses technology
from the physics environment that was
just purely for research that is now
embedded in in hospitals all around the
world medicine needs
funding in its own right of course it
does
but it's had so much input from
fundamental ideas fundamental physics
ideas for a start and chemistry
and radioisotopes that you know
everywhere in in medicine
that to simply
simply say yeah we should be putting all
of this into medicine for example is not
the way to make the major breakthroughs
that will help people in the future in
medicine either what makes us special
what makes us special is our inquisitive
nature we want to know about the
universe we want to know about beautiful
pictures and admire them we want to know
about what makes the universe tick
and we should have the facilities to be
able to invest in
all of these
then on the outside the bulk of the
detector here is actually for stopping
the muons these elementary particles
which are
like electrons but 200 times heavier
and they're so important because if you
find a muon it tells you that something
really high energy has happened they're
very difficult to create and so you if
if a new one's detected and and they're
very difficult to detect they just shoot
through all the other things we've been
describing